a horrifying terrorist attack on Muslims
in Christchurch shakes the world
President Trump runs into Republican
resistance over his national emergency
and we checked the mailbag i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the events in New Zealand are disturbing
and horrifying in every possible way
naturally their folks on Twitter and in
the media who will politicize all of
this because that is what we do
unfortunately in our in our fast-moving
media world we'll talk about all of this
stuff we'll talk about what exactly
happened in Christchurch the reactions
of folks it's just it's horrifying it
everywhere we'll get to all that first
let's talk about you losing your hair
losing your hair sucks you don't realize
how much you care about your hair until
you start losing it which is why you
should be using keeps the easiest most
affordable way to keep the hair that you
have fda-approved products used to cost
so much but now thanks to keeps they're
finally inexpensive and easy to get for
five minutes now in just a buck a day
you're never gonna have to worry about
hair loss again getting started with
keeps is so easy sign up takes less than
five minutes
just answer a few questions snap some
photos of your hair a licensed physician
will then review your information online
and recommend the right treatment for
you it is then shipped directly to your
door every month every three months
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda-approved hair loss products
out there some of you probably tried
them before you've probably never gotten
them for this price however keeps is
only ten bucks to 35 bucks a month plus
now you can get your very first month
for free and to hell the deal forgetting
to keep your hair to receive your first
month of treatment for free go to keeps
calm / Ben that's ke EPS calm / Ben
that's a free month of treatment right
now at keeps calm / Ben keeps hair today
hair tomorrow go check them out right
now ke e PS calm / had no reason to lose
your hair when you can stop it from
happening and get a free month of
treatment today
it keeps calm / Ben great service make
sure that you don't lose your hair today
okay let's start with with obviously
stomach-churning horrifying evil white
supremacist terror attack on mosques in
New Zealand if you didn't lose sleep
last night it's because you'd weren't
following the story closely closely
enough if you don't feel sick to your
stomach after after reading the the
coverage of all of this after after
reading about the evil of the
participants in this then legitimately
you're not paying close enough attention
to the story it is it is utterly
horrifying in every conceivable way New
York Times reporting 49 people were
killed 49 people were killed in
shootings at two mosques in central
Christchurch New Zealand on Friday in a
terrorist attack to pry
Minister Jacinda our turn described as
extraordinary and unprecedented act of
violence obviously this was a white
supremacist a terror attack that was
driven at Islamic centres officials said
one man in his late 20s had been charged
with murder that two explosive devices
were found attached to a vehicle that
they had stopped a Muslim leader in New
Zealand said the attack was especially
shocking it took place around Friday
prayer so it was coordinated to be when
the mosque were most full a gunman
streamed a live video of the attack on
Facebook he appeared to have posted a
manifesto online we have a rule of daily
wear this is established about a year
and a half ago two years ago saying we
will not name any mass shooter will not
name terrorists we will not name the
people who who murder innocents in the
name of their politics we're not going
to do that we are also not going to read
the terrorist manifesto today we are not
going to give credence to his thoughts
we will mention his politics only to the
extent that it is necessary to discuss
the overarching political issues that
affect the world and affect our nation
but we are not going to quote his
manifesto we are not going to go out of
our way to to lend any sort of support
or credence to not only his manifesto
but to the notion that his manifesto
should be used as a guidebook for others
what these folks want what evil
terrorists want is attention that's why
they commit terrorist attacks that's why
this guy live streamed a video of his
attack on Facebook and it shows you that
in our two connected world we've got a
real problem because if you are seeking
fame if you are seeking notoriety then
you all you have to do is commit an act
of evil with a camera in your hand we've
seen this over and over and over again
now stop watching the videos delete the
videos suck the air out of the room do
not provide the impetus for future
people future monsters monstrous evil
people to do stuff like this it's just
it's horrific and there's also the sense
of air SATs community that is created
for white supremacists online who are
able because of the internet to find
people who think like them in the dark
niches of Western society and non
Western society able to find these dark
niches of people who think like them and
who cheer when this sort of stuff
happens and who who act performative Lee
for the sake of others you see this when
it comes to a lot of bleep
hosting online a sort of performative
nature of harassing people bothering
people annoying people but and that's
you know that's that's an aspect of free
speech it's not something I like but
it's an aspect of free speech that we
all have to just deal with when that
bleeds over into the real world where
performance becomes violence and where
people are performing acts of violence
even in order to receive the cheers of
others we have to wonder whether are
connected universe is a little bit too
connected because the truth is it's not
real connection real connection is the
connection that we forged with each
other when we are offline how many of
your best friends are people that you
meet online and never meet in person how
many of the people that you actually
connect with are people that you are
just talking to in a chat room or on a
reddit board the answer is probably not
many most of the deep connections in
your life are the people who you meet
and because we don't spend enough time
out in the world being with other people
it allows us to other other people it
allows us to treat other people as
though they're foreign to us as though
they are monsters as though there are to
be clubbed or destroyed in some way and
that's that's terrible it's it really is
because the reality is when we treat
each other face to face when we see each
other face to face it is exorbitantly
rare in good societies and decent
societies that we treat each other badly
when we treat each other face to face
and that's why something like this is so
shocking when the sort of vile
underbelly of the internet brews up into
the real world and ends with deadly
consequences it really is that's not a
call for a censorship it's a call for
human beings to be better it's a call
for all of us to try harder it's a call
for for everyone to get off line and
start interacting with people with whom
they may not agree and who they may not
know the prime minister of New Zealand
had a few words to say about this here's
what she had to say it is clear that
this is one of New Zealand's darkest
days clearly what has happened here is
an extraordinary and unprecedented act
of violence many of those who will have
been directly affected by the shooting
may be migrants to New Zealand they may
even be refugees here they have chosen
to make New Zealand their home in it is
the
they are us the person who has
perpetuated this violence against us is
not they have no place in New Zealand
there is no place in New Zealand for
such acts of extreme and unprecedented
violence which is it is clear this act
was for now my thoughts and I'm sure the
thoughts of all New Zealanders with
those who have been affected and also
with their families
my thoughts also to those in
Christchurch who are still dealing with
an unfolding situation now we'll treat
the media response to all this in just a
second after we bring you the
information because the media response
has been in many cases irresponsible
over-the-top attempting to cast blame as
a first resort attempting to to
politicize this stuff politicians
particularly one particularly foolish
politician has gotten an inordinate
amounts of attention tweeting out
ridiculous things first let me give you
the rest of the information shots were
fired at Alma mosque on Deans Avenue in
the centre of the city and at Lynwood
mosque about three miles away the police
said the country's Police Commissioner
Mike Bush said in an evening news
conference that 41 people had been
killed at all nor mosque and seven at
Lynwood mosque and another victim had
died at Christchurch Hospital David
meets the chief executive of the
Canterbury District Health Board said
that 48 people including young children
were being treated for injuries at the
hospital he said the injuries included
gunshot wounds and range from critical
to minor the International Committee of
the Red Cross created a page for
reporting the names of people who are
missing or accounted for the police said
that four people including three men and
one woman had been taken into custody
prime minister Scott Morrison of
Australia said that one of them was
Australian mr. Bush said that a man in
his late 20s had been charged with
murder and would appear in Christchurch
Court on Saturday morning a number of
firearms were recovered from the scenes
of the shootings he said by the way
written on the firearms were the names
of other mass murderers who had
particularly targeted mosques of the
three others who were detained the
police commissioner said that one might
have had nothing to do with the attack
and the police were working to determine
how the other two might have been
involved
none of those detained were on security
watch lists two explosive devices were
found on one vehicle mr. Bush said
adding that the police had defused one
and were in the process of defusing the
other mr. Bush had urged people not to
go to mosque anywhere in New Zealand on
Friday he also urged mosques mosques
national
to close your doors until you hear from
us again which is just horrifying
shutting down religious institutions
because evil people are attempting to
kill people at religious institutions is
just insane yeah yeah Shara Lee who is
an iranian-born reporter in the United
States he tweeted out that it takes a
certain amount bravery for people to
identify publicly as religious and
that's true for people who choose to
wear hijab it's true of people who
choose to wear sidelocks if you're
Jewish or yarmulkes it's true for a wide
variety of people
that's not bravery that's just how
people live that's how people live it's
a choice that they've made and when I
see somebody who's chosen to wear a
hijab and it's one of the reasons I was
in favor of the Congress changing its
rules to allow Ilhan Omar who I think is
terrible for a lot of other reasons but
for this I think that it's great
Congress changing his rules to allow
Ilhan Omar to cover her head on the
floor of the Congress if she chooses to
do so that's that's a wonderful thing
because when you see other people who
are attempting to reach out see
something larger to them than themselves
people who are attempting to recognize
that they are subject to a morality
above themselves that's a good thing
that's a good thing and for people to
despise that and try and murder people
because of that is such an act of
tremendous tremendous evil there's a 17
minute video posted to Facebook showing
part of the attack Facebook didn't see
it in time so they didn't take it down
in time the clip which may have been
taken from a helmet camera worn by a
gunman begins behind the wheel of a car
the man whose face can occasionally be
seen in the rearview mirror drives
through the streets of Christchurch
before pulling up to the on lower mosque
beside the sprawling Hagley Park he
approaches the mosque on foot his weapon
visible and begins shooting at people at
the entrance what follows is a heroine
nearly two minutes of his firing on
worshippers at one point the government
exits the mosque and fires in both
directions down the sidewalk before
returning to his car for another gun
which like the others was inscribed with
numbers symbols or messages when he
re-enters the mosque he shoots at
several bodies at close range the video
is absolutely horrendous people should
absolutely not watch it or give it
coverage he also posted a white
nationalist manifesto on Twitter and
8chan and people have of course been
perusing this to see if they can cast
aspersions at American political figures
the h n post included a link to the
gunman's Facebook page where he said he
would broadcast the live video of the
attack there in
in the middle of this this evil video
felix Kilburg who is pewdiepie youtube
celebrity i've been on his meme review
he distance himself from the attacks
because he's not responsible for the
attach and here's where the media start
to lose it the media start suggesting
that because kelberg was mentioned by
this guy somehow he is responsible for
the attacks no there is a sick online
meme world where people make references
to other people who are online in order
to gain attention or an older or in
order to polarize people who don't
understand anything about Miam world
take everything that the folks who are
doing in these chat rooms these these
these threads they take all of that
seriously ok that is that is not correct
not only should all of it not be taken
seriously some of it is directly is
directly an attempt to generate
headlines some of it is directly in
attempt to implicate people who are not
responsible for things you've seen
Candice Owens name mentioned in this
person's manifesto Candice Owens has
nothing to do with this guy and it's
actually pretty obvious from the
manifesto itself that he is naming
Candice Owen specifically to cause
political rifts the one thing that is
clear from this white nationalist
manifesto that this piece of human wrote
one thing that is that is absolutely
clear from that is that he wanted to
drive political division he was seeking
to drive political division in the West
that would break down along Rachel
racial lines and then he could claim
that he had started race war that was
his intent in all of this and anybody
who's perpetuating that is he's helping
him do his work you know that's what he
wanted we'll get to more of this in just
a second first let's talk about how
you're dressing you know that old suit
that you got from the local department
store them look that good what you need
is a made-to-measure
suit from endo chino endo chino is the
world's most exciting of made-to-measure
menswear company they make suits in
shirts to your exact measurements for an
unparalleled fit and comfort if you're
looking to get married they have tons of
options for people looking to outfit
their wedding party dudes love the wide
selection of high quality fabrics and
colors to choose from not to mention the
option to personalize the details
including lapel winding pockets buttons
writing your own monogram here's how it
works you can visit a stylist at their
showroom and have them take your
measurements personally it's really fun
it's really cool I've done it myself or
you can measure at home and shop online
at endo Chino comm you can choose your
fabric inside and out choose your design
customizations submit your measurements
with your choices this week my listeners
can get any premium Indo Chino suit for
just three hundred fifty nine dollars at
Chino calm when you enter Shapiro at
checkout that is 50% off the regular
price for a made-to-measure premium suit
plus shipping is free that is Indo Chino
comm promo code Shapiro for any premium
suit for just 359 bucks and free
shipping
it's an incredible deal for a premium
made-to-measure suit once you go custom
you're not going to want to go back go
check out Indo Chino calm right now use
promo code Shapiro for any premium suit
just 359 bucks and free shipping 50% off
the regular price from made-to-measure
menswear premium suit back to this
horrendous story so people have been
trying to figure out how exactly they
curbed social media what to do about
social media that really is probably not
the answer other than actual attempts to
create violence I've said for a long
time you don't get to attribute violence
to people unless they are openly calling
for violence if they are openly calling
for violence that's a violation of the
First Amendment and those posts should
not be available anywhere the fact that
Facebook YouTube Twitter Instagram the
fact that they've been looking to take
down political posts political posts
they don't like as opposed to targeting
actual posts that inflame violence that
are directly attempting to inflame
violence is a blot on the record of
these tech companies the 17 minute video
apparently could be found on Facebook
YouTube Twitter and Instagram more than
an hour after being posted in order to
evade detection people were cropping the
video or posting the text as manifesto
of the manifesto as an image both of
which are techniques used to evade
automated systems that find and delete
the content Facebook has already
invested an enormous amount of resources
they can't be perfect here of course and
especially when it comes from an account
that they weren't actively following
still the tech companies need to focus a
little more if they can I'm cracking
down on incipient violence and a little
bit less on the politics that they
particularly do not like now now to the
politics of the situation so we are
already seeing the coverage turned
toward what drove this this evil
disgusting piece of human debris to do
all of this and many in the media think
they found their answer and their answer
is Trump so there is an article from Al
Jazeera in which they point out that the
manifesto mentions
President Trump does not mention that
President Trump is specifically
denounced for his politics this is a 74
page dossier hailing Trump as a quote
symbol of renewed white identity and
common purpose but the quote continues
that this person does not believe in
Trump's politics and does not believe in
his values so here is the point when you
look at manifestos like this first of
all it is not coherent other than a
generalized hatred for people who are
not of white identity second of all the
manifesto itself is me Murray it is
designed in order to heighten conflict
it is designed to call out certain
people to get them centered in the media
it is not designed as an active coherent
call to arms but the media covering it
that way are doing so for political
purposes there are a lot of things that
are said in here the guy calls himself
an eco anarchist or an eco fascist is
what he called himself they're not
quoting that part because it doesn't
meet their narrative the fact is that
you shouldn't be looking at this guy as
anything other than an evil white
supremacist because that's the
overarching message of what he did but
instead what was what we're trying to do
is now attribute his actions to others
now there are people who have reacted
badly on both sides of the political
aisle I hesitate even to to label
senator Frazier anning a member of the
the the Australian party as a as a right
winger given this kind of rhetoric but
he he tweeted out one of the worst
statements I have ever seen quote does
anyone still dispute the link between
Muslim immigration and violence are you
insane are you an insane person Muslims
were just massacred this is not Muslim
immigrants causing violence this is
Muslim immigrants being the being the
victims of violence what in the absolute
hell I mean this is this is but this guy
has a long record of this sort of thing
the reason people are turning to the
rhetoric question is because they can't
turn to the gun control question the
reason they can't turn to the gun
control question is because New Zealand
law is some of the most heavily gun
controlled on planet earth murders are
rare in New Zealand reports the New York
Times gun homicides are even rarer there
were 35 murders countrywide in 2017
since 2007 gun homicides have been in
the single digits every year except 2009
but there are plenty of guns there were
1.2
in registered firearms in the country of
4.6 million people in 2017 which just
goes to show you that high levels of gun
ownership don't necessarily mean high
levels of gun violence it depends who
owns the gun New Zealand law allows any
person age 16 or older with an entry
level firearm license to keep any number
of common rifles and shotguns most guns
can be purchased without being tracked
by law enforcement officials with that
said there are still some very heavy gun
control regulations in New Zealand's
virtually every person who owns a
firearm has to be registered
the media is trying to turn this into a
gun control debate but the fact is that
the that compared to the United States
their gun control is pretty serious it's
pretty serious so potential gun owners
in New Zealand have to pass a police
background check for example the gun
laws in Australia were tightened
following a 1996 mass shooting in which
35 people were killed by a lone gunman
in Tasmania within two weeks Australian
lawmakers banned rapid-fire rifles and
shotguns and introduced tighter laws
governing ownership of other weapons New
Zealand has some of these laws on the
books and of course they have an
incredibly low murder rate so this is
really not about gun control nonetheless
what you are seeing from some people is
a call for gun control you're also
seeing people trot out their slogans at
the wrong time so one of the big things
that happens in the United States is
whenever there is a massacre of some
sort people immediately say that their
thoughts and prayers are with the folks
who are hurt which is a way of
expressing empathy aren't we told that
in politics and in life sympathy and
empathy are good things and if I say
that I'm praying for people who just
lost loved ones that that is my
expression of care for them and yet it
has become a thing in the United States
that if you say thoughts and prayers
what that really is is a way of you
avoiding the harder discussions about
policy and rhetoric there's only one
problem this was a massacre carried out
at a mosque where people were
legitimately praying because they wanted
to be in consonance with something
higher than themselves
that's a nonstop Alexandra Ocasio Cortes
very fresh and very face from tweeting
out quote at first I thought of saying
imagine being told your house of faith
isn't safe anymore but I couldn't say
imagine because of Charleston Pittsburgh
Sutherland Springs
what good are your thoughts and prayers
when they don't even keep the pews safe
what the hell does she even mean by that
these were Muslims religious Muslims
praying to Allah they were there to pray
they were there to commune with
something greater
what good are your thoughts and prayers
when they don't even keep the pew safe
this is a fundamental misunderstanding
of what religion does religion does not
suggest that if you pray you will be
safer religion suggests that if you pray
you may become better because you're
thinking about something greater than
yourself and then she tries to walk this
absolute crap back
she says this is a time of great
vulnerability for our communities we
must come together fight for each other
and stand up for neighbors isolation
dehumanizing stereotypes hysterical
conspiracy theories in hatred ultimately
lead to the anarchy of violence we
cannot stand for it fine
then she says this thoughts and prayers
is a reference to the NRA z' phrase used
to deflect conversation away from policy
change during tragedies not directed to
the Prime Minister our gern who I
greatly admire well no thoughts and
prayers is not an NRA phrase thoughts
and prayers a phrase that is used by
decent people all around the world for
legitimately centuries to suggest that
thoughts and prayers is just a way to
shirk responsibility for a gun control
debate that you feel like having at this
particular time is that the blood still
on the pavement just just horrifying but
of course the whole thing is horrifying
and the reaction is horrifying the truth
is every human being of decency is
united on this everybody believes that
this human piece of excrement should pay
whatever is the ultimate price in New
Zealand and so should anybody who is
associated with this act of absolutely
evil terror everyone agrees on this
stuff and people who are trying to
generate false division based on the
fact that they don't like Trump or they
don't like guns or they don't like
environmentalism whoever is trying to
turn this into a political thing today
other than condemning the ideology of
the terrorists okay the ideology of the
terrorists is a white supremacist
ideology it is fully evil it is fully
evil to suggest that if a Muslim lives
in your neighborhood that Muslim
deserves to die because they are a
threat to your white majority it is
sheer absolute Sikh garbage it is you
can have questions about the nature of
radical Islam that is not the same thing
as suggesting that a Muslim in your
neighborhood is a terrorist who's
supposed to be shot at a mosque it's
disgusting and anybody who is suggesting
today that white supremacism
doesn't have victims is of course being
ignorant of the reality of the modern
world it is just untrue that sort of
stuff should be condemned the ideology
of the killer should be condemned now
what is wrong is to extend that ideology
to people who do not believe it so you
see some people on the political left
doing today taking that ideology and
saying well you believe that don't you
know typical mainline conservatives do
not believe this stuff they forcibly
fight back against this stuff there's a
reason that the same way to Prem assists
on 4chan are not big fans of a lot of
conservatives I mean again this guy's
manifesto itself said that he was not a
conservative and didn't like
conservatism because he felt it hadn't
conserved okay the fact is white
supremacy is indeed evil we should all
be front and forward in condemning the
tribal politics of race it's horrifying
and it has impact we should I don't
understand why there's division on on
when this sort of stuff happens I
understand that people want to use
flashpoints to push their particular
politics I understand that but it does
nothing but tear apart a civilization
that is united on acts of evil like this
sort of stuff all right in just a second
we'll turn to President Trump national
emergency declaration first let's talk
about life insurance so the fact is that
every responsible person should have
life insurance if you have a wife if you
have a mortgage if you have kids you
have people who depend on your income
you ought to have life insurance and you
ought to have other insurance too and
policy genius is the easy way to get
this insurance in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find the best policy for you when you
apply online the advisors at policy
genius will handle all the red tape for
you they will even negotiate your rate
with the insurance company no commission
sales agents no hidden fees just helpful
advice and personalized service policy
genius doesn't just do life insurance
they also make it easy to find the right
home insurance auto insurance or
disability insurance they are your
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you find life insurance puzzling
head on over to policy genius com in two
minutes you can compare quotes find the
right policy and save up to 40% doing it
policy genius is the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance policy genius
head on over there be a responsible
person make sure you have the insurance
that your family needs policy genius two
minutes compare quotes find that right
policy save up to 40% doing it policy
genius will do life insurance health
insurance
home insurance disability insurance they
have all sorts of wonderful resources
for you policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance okay
final note I just want to reiterate when
it comes to stuff like this we live in a
world where flashpoints are used in
order to politically polarized I don't
legitimately know I don't legitimately
know where there should be serious
political difference on the evil of this
and why you would point fingers at
people who are not responsible for
things unless you are badly motivated I
don't know why you would do that
everybody is united in condemning this
as well they should be just like
everybody was united in condemning the
shooting at the Texas church or at the
South Carolina Church we are all united
when it comes to fighting acts of evil
it's why we have a civilization if we
were not united in fighting acts of evil
we would not have a civilization and
casting aspersions at people who believe
the same way that you do that this is an
act of tremendous evil and that the
ideology that supports this act of evil
is itself evil that fighting those
people are lumping them in with the bad
guys that is in and of itself horrifying
and and disgusting it's it's really bad
it's really bad stuff okay let's move on
to President Trump and his emergency
declaration so the Senate voted
yesterday to reject president Trump's
emergency declaration immediately Trump
tweeted veto all capital letters the
sentence resolution was passed 59 to 41
to overturn his national emergency
declaration them saying we didn't
delegate you this kind of power and you
are not allowed to simply overrule us by
declaring a national emergency and it
does show that the national emergency
power is to a certain extent being
abused because the fact is that the
national emergency act was designed to
allow the president to act in the
absence of congressional opinion making
or weighing in the reason to Eclair
national emergency is you don't actually
have time to go to Congress for the
Appropriations and just declared an
emergency was the first time that I
think has ever happened where Congress
has explicitly rejected a national
emergency declaration from the president
the reason for that because the
president negotiated with Congress he
didn't get what he wanted and then he
declared a national emergency that is a
violation of the constitutional order
that is not how the Constitution is
supposed to work
President Trump said he was going to
veto this he said I look forward to
vetoing the just passed Democrat
inspired resolution which would open
border
while increasing crime drugs and
trafficking in our country I think all
of the strong Republicans who voted to
support border security and our
desperately needed wall now I know a lot
of Senators and members of the House who
voted in favor of upholding the national
emergency declaration I don't think that
that was the right move I don't think
that was the constitutional move and in
fact you saw a bunch of Republicans who
switched their position on this simply
because President Trump does have a
massive amount of support the fact is
that a bunch of senators flipped on this
most prominently senator Ben Sasse of
Nebraska he had said earlier we
absolutely have a crisis at the border
but as a constitutional conservative I
don't want a future Democratic president
unilaterally rewriting gun laws or
climate policy if we get used to
presidents just declaring an emergency
anytime they can't get what they want
from Congress it will be almost
impossible to go back to a
constitutional system of checks and
balances over the past decades the
legislative branch has given away too
much power and the executive branch has
taken too much power that seems like a
pretty good predicate for voting against
the national emergency declaration and
then he voted in favor of the national
emergency declaration he said the reason
he did so is because he and Mike Lee had
put forward a bill that would have
curbed generally the powers to declare a
national emergency and that bill had not
been had not been agreed to by the
president
well then why are you voting with him on
this national emergency that still
doesn't answer the question the fact is
this national emergency the one being
declared right now is not in fact
legally a national emergency
it is a national emergency in the con
parlance it is something that the
Congress ought to do something about we
ought to have a wall the president
doesn't get to overstep his boundaries
just because he's doing something you
like the measure of a principle is
whether if the violation of the
principle accomplishes something that
you want you are for it or against it so
if you have a principle and then it
turns out the tossing out the principle
in order to get something done appeals
to you so you toss out the principle
then you really didn't have the
principle to begin with you had a
politics of convenience it's not just
senators ass who flipped on this sort of
thing senator Thom Tillis wrote a full
op eds aying that he was not in favor of
the national emergency declaration he
announced he would vote to terminate the
national emergency declaration and then
he changed his mind and voted against
terminating the national emergency
declaration and listen I understand that
there is severe pressure on these
senators from people who are sitting
home and who are thinking
okay well all this really comes down to
is do you want to protect the border or
not but that is a failure to educate
your own voters which is part of the job
and there's been this move in national
politics toward we will just appease
whichever voters are in front of us
that's our job to give the voters what
they want well that's half your job the
other half of your job is to help shape
what voters want it's to convince voters
it's to go back home and give people the
hard messages if you're not doing that
then you are not acting as a good
representative this is the difference
between the sort of straight democratic
representation model and the Burkean
model of representation Edmund Burke
famously wrote that if you were a
representative then it was not just your
job to represent the temporary wishes of
the public it was your job to represent
to act as your own conscience they
elected you to use your own conscience
and if the people don't like it then I
suppose they can turn you out but they
should give you a solid listen they
should give you a solid listen again I
think a Republican this this should have
passed with an overwhelming
supermajority it did not that is that is
lack of principle on the part of a lot
of Republicans including many
Republicans with whom I generally agree
and I think there is a case to be made I
think that you've heard representative
Dan Crenshaw make it that if you really
believe that it is legal for the
president to declare a national
emergency under current powers then you
vote in favor of this but there are a
bunch of people who said the president
doesn't have those powers under the
national emergencies act and then they
voted in favor of the president
exercising powers he doesn't have that's
bad and I hear the excuses listen I hear
the excuses the excuse that Democrats
would do this it would do the exact same
thing that's true that's why I'm not a
Democrat it is true Democrats would go
along with violations of the
constitutional order which is why again
I am NOT a Democrat so I guess you can
continue to just go along with whatever
the president wants if it mirrors your
political preferences but don't claim to
be a constitutional conservative if you
do okay coming up we're gonna talk about
beta O'Rourke and we're gonna jump into
the mailbag first you are going to have
to subscribe over at Daley wire.com for
a few weeks we've been featuring a
different daily wider annual subscriber
every Friday as a thank you for helping
support what we do over here today I
want to give a shout out to Malcolm Chua
at CI a CAI en ta I on Twitter
as you can see in this photo Malcolm's
adorable daughter yes I am assuming her
sex put her piggy bank savings into
becoming a daily wire annual subscriber
and then demands it obviously that dad
take a picture of her with the tumbler
and then post it on Twitter
either that or Malcolm is a subscriber
and his daughter was just kind of
sitting there it's hard to tell which
one is true anyway Malcolm thank you for
being a subscriber we really do
appreciate it if you want to experience
the rush of adrenaline and joy Malcolm
is surely fueling at this very instant
you have to be a daily wire annual
subscriber and you have to post a photo
of your tumblr on either twitter or
instagram with the hashtag leftist
year's tumblr you can even be in that
photo if you would like to become a
subscriber go to daily wire comm click
on the subscribe button at the top of
the page and then send us your tumblr
pics if you want a chance at getting a
shout out on this show there's also so
much great stuff that you get when you
become a subscriber / it's a Lee Weyer
it means that you got access to the
additional 2 hours of the showw that we
do every day just for you you can ask me
questions during the breaks will answer
your questions in the mailbag when we
have conversations and when we do
episodes of the conversation you can ask
questions actually next week we have a
special episode of the conversation it's
a live book signing if you go over to
premier collectibles calm / ben shapiro
then you can actually buy a copy a
signed copy of my book when you do that
for this time only you'll be able to
actually i'll answer your questions even
if you're not a subscriber so go over to
premier collectibles calm / ben shapiro
we're doing that next Wednesday so stick
around to daily where to check that out
again it's 99 bucks a year for the
annual that's the one that you want it
is it is cheaper than the monthly and
you also get the leftist here's tumbler
I also make sure that you go subscribe
over at YouTube and iTunes make sure
that you leave us a review we always
appreciate we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay meanwhile beta beta right so he is
he is running and the blowback has begun
the blowback has begun to to beta or
work there is a piece today in the New
York Times all about how beta O'Rourke
is too white and you knew this was
coming you knew that it was going to
happen that his that he was going to be
criticized for being too privileged I
mentioned yesterday that was astonishing
to me that the media hadn't already
jumped on this the fact that beta
O'Rourke grew up exorbitantly wealthy
and exorbitantly powerful in a fairly
small town and that he escaped a couple
of misdemeanor transgressions including
a DWI in which he apparently crossed the
median Lyon Lane rammed into somebody
and then ran away that he was able to
spend most of his 20s running around the
country in a crappy punk-rock band with
no blowback and I was asking why aren't
Democrats pointing this out I thought
this is the party of inspiring personal
stories and intersectionality and
opposing white privilege and all of that
well all I had to do is wait 24 hours
asti at Herndon is a columnist over at
the New York Times he writes in beta
O'Rourke's announcement his wife's
silence stands out oh boy get ready beta
O'Rourke the charismatic Texas Democrat
and former member of the House of
Representatives announced his
presidential campaign in a video on
Thursday the three minute clip quickly
racked up thousands of shares with some
viewers excited by the prospect of his
out of nowhere political rise but others
were put off by how his campaigns
employed an age-old trope in American
political theater the silent supportive
wife throughout the video mister
O'Rourke's wife sat amy sat quietly by
her husband's side periodically grasping
his hand as he outlined his campaign
vision and occasionally she smiled and
gazed okay now I have a question why is
this such a bad thing they're a bunch of
tweets people saying I'm so sick of
wives being forced to silently gaze ok
so my wife who is in fact a doctor does
not follow politics supremely closely
when people have ever had asked her if I
would ever run for office she said god I
hope not
my wife doesn't like being in the public
spotlight if she were in some sort of
campaign commercial if I asked her you
know what sweetheart I want to show a
kinder world to the face would you be in
the campaign commercial you think she
actually wants me to kick at her so she
can talk about tax policy or is it
possible that she would be supporting my
dream in the same way that I have
supported her dreams I mean there are a
lot of rips on beta o'rourke I don't
think the
one is particularly fair nonetheless
he's getting hit for it because his wife
is not speaking in his campaign video
which is absurd when was the last time
you heard somebody say where's Kamala
Harris's husband and why isn't he
speaking in her campaign videos because
we're not electing that person why would
we the presence of the spouse is meant
to show that this is a human okay it's
meant to it's meant to Hue you to the
fact that bado is a human which i agree
with he may not be my favorite human but
he is a human this is such an unfair rip
but it shows where the Democratic head
is at or where a lot of Democrats are at
is what this this column says so absurd
throughout the 1980s Nancy Reagan and
Barbara Bush could be found next to
their presidential husbands often
silently supporting them in big moments
more recently buoyed by Hillary
Clinton's active role in her husband's
campaigns many elected officials have
leaned on their partners as high-profile
surrogates in the current presidential
race Jane Sanders wife of Bernie Sanders
of Vermont enjoyed a prominent
behind-the-scenes role and gave a speech
at his initial campaign rally Wow
mr. o'roarke video however struck some
observers as especially out of place in
a presidential race in which more
democratic women are running for
president than ever before among several
of these women the husbands are rarely
seen so which is it
should the spouse be seen or should the
spouse be heard or should this pass be
neither which is it on his first day of
campaigning in a seemingly offhand
comment mr. Orrick joked about his wife
saying she was raising their children
sometimes with my help his comment to
listen to both laughter and derision
hey I don't understand why is that and
then the following sentence is the best
part this is not the first time mr.
o'roarke has been accused of appearing
to rebel and his advantages as a white
male in an increasingly diverse
Democratic Party no you dolt that is not
what he was saying again how am i
finding myself defending bata or how did
this happen
have we created a world where the guy
that I mock is a pseudo pothead who
spends his days on the quad playing
guitar for the for the gullible women
how am i defending beta O'Rourke how
because you people are so crazy that you
forced me into defending beta O'Rourke
if I say about my wife that she spends
an enormous amount of time raising our
children sometimes with my help that is
not to riding her that is to riding me
that is beta or rogue saying that his
wife is a hair
and he is a person who is not doing his
fair share that's ridiculous to
criticize him for that but this
columnist for The New York Times says as
he announced his campaign complete with
the profile in Vanity Fair in which he
hinted he was born to run for president
detractors pointed out that prominent
black Democrats who lost their 2018
campaigns including Stacey Abrams in
Georgia and Andrew Gilliam in Florida
are not running for president well first
of all that's only for now both of them
have said that they are considering it
for weeks before his presidential loud
announcement a work traveled across the
country as he wrestled privately with
whether to run and wrote musings on his
medium account this was jokes from
several comedians and prominent social
voices who compared his public agonising
with the stereotypical tendency for men
to refuse to commit to relationships
particularly romantic ones hey that of
course is absolutely true nonetheless
that this sort of rip is amazing by the
way you know what I just noticed this is
not an opinion column this is not an
opinion column the guy who wrote this is
a reporter you get to the bottom and it
reads like an opinion calm you get to
the bottom and it says that there are a
couple of reporters who helped with this
column and says Megan felling Sergio
pankaja and on Charlie Singhvi
contributed any Wow justly buys that the
New York Times is so strongly you can
legitimately read one of their news
pieces as though it's an op-ed and not
notice until you hit the end but that
just shows you where bado is going to
fall flat with a certain segment of the
Democratic Party it's the same place by
the way that Joe Biden is going to fall
flat it's the same place that Joe Biden
is going to fall Platt with that
intersectional base of the Democratic
Party Bernie Sanders can escape that
because Bernie Sanders has that
progressive base that is locked in
that's why I think people are
overestimating bado not under estimating
bado at this point I think people think
that his charm offensive what the media
will have some sort of significant
impact in the primaries I think that
that stuff's gonna wear off it's gonna
wear real thin really quickly Barack
Obama had the capacity to carry both the
intersectional core as well as the
media's love not the same thing for bado
O'Rourke by the way bado is not doing a
wonderful job on the campaign trail he's
going around making gaffes basically
yesterday he did some sort of Instagram
where he asked people for gas money
because he's driving his minivan but he
just told us that we were all going to
die thanks
to climate change and here he is at a
gas station asking for money so we've
got 12 gallon and the Dodge Grand
Caravan causes 28 dollars and 50% the
gin join thank you what in the what in
okay so I thought that again I guess
he's just living in the world like a OC
you know just living in the world one of
the beautiful things about being a
Democrat is you can actively ask for gas
money as though you're a beta or work
when he's 25 years old not 45 years old
and people will think that this is a
cool thing to do also beta suggested of
course that the green New Deal is just
like Normandy so at the same time he's
asking for gas money he's saying the
green New Deal is like Normandy those
who preceded us right those who run the
beaches in Normandy those who face an
existential threat to Western democracy
and our way of life they showed us the
way we can all come together we can
unite we can marshal the resources and
we can convene the countries of the
world that's why they call us the
indispensable nation okay so and we're
indispensable also give me gas money
we're all gonna die in 12 years also can
I get in this minivan and spew some
carbon emissions into the air guys I'm
just living in the world okay time for
some mailbag because it is a Friday Ryan
says hi Ben I'd be curious to know your
perspective on the court's ruling that
Remington can be sued in connection with
the tragic Sandy Hook shooting this is
an absurd ruling an absurd ruling there
is a court that ruled for those who
missed it that Remington can be sued in
court because the shooter in Sandy Hook
used an ar-15 manufactured by Remington
that is the height of silly okay that is
the same thing as suggesting that Ford
can be sued because you drove your Ford
into a storefront hey it's a vehicle
they didn't tell you how to drive it the
gun was not made to shoot children it
was made to defend against people who
tried to shoot children
that's what guns are made for if you
want to sue the state for failing to do
proper background checks that's more
understandable but if you're
going to sue remington that theory of
products liability is a complete fail
products liability generally there are
only a couple of classes of products
liability and i'm trying to remember all
the way back to law school which was now
twelve years ago
but thinking back to law school they're
only a couple of lines of product
liability there is design flaws and then
there's manufacturing flaws design flaws
are that i designed a product that is
designed badly and is going to harm you
because of its design and the other one
is a manufacturing flaw there's
something in the machine itself that is
broken and that broke and that hurt you
it's not a design flaw when the gun
works exactly how it's supposed to work
it is just being in by a complete evil
piece of garbage and innocent people
because the gun was not designed to for
that purpose this is like suing a knife
manufacturer for Amuro j simpson's
alleged murder of his of his ex-wife
james says hi ben do you think the
leftist radical is pushing further and
further away from the traditional
democrats could eventually form a third
political party if so what consequences
could you foresee now i don't see that
happening i think that what we've seen
in the last ten years is basically
ideological shifts within these parties
it's easier to take over an established
party than it is to start a new party in
the united states the libertarian party
proves that legitimately every
presidential election cycle Craig says
hey Ben I'm addicted to watching atheist
versus religion debates on YouTube
specifically Christopher Hitchens
debating rabbi shmuel II botella in
light of your upcoming book what are
your current thoughts on the debate
between atheists and theists have you
ever ret met Rabbi Shmuley
thanks Craig no I I have not actually
met Rabbi Shmuley as far as the debate
between atheists and theists you know
I've done I've done a couple of these so
I've had discussion more discussions
than debates I've had discussions with
Sam Harris a couple of times once on his
podcast once on mine I've had
discussions with with Michael Shermer a
friend of mine who happens to be the
editor of skeptic magazine and is best
described as sort of an agnostic /
atheist the the real question about the
argument between atheism and theism is
that I don't think both sides actually
understand each other mainly I think
atheists don't understand theists I
think that a lot of atheists seem to
believe that if they argue against the
Bible that this is somehow an argument
against theism itself it is not that if
they just cited a couple of out of
context verses from the Bible they're
going to shatter the faith of people who
believe in it that is not the
to happen that if there is an order to
nature that somehow this is a disproving
of God's presence or that if you are a
believer in Darwinian evolution that
somehow this just proves God's presence
because it looks like an order without a
designer well who designed that order
all that theists believe is that there
is a design to order to the universe and
that that order to the universe was was
created by an active mind that's the
basis of theism and it's not really a
disprovable thesis and there are some
people who have attempted to put and
then you stack up evidence on both sides
you see which is more likely which is
less likely so I find these sorts of
things interesting what I do find is
that for a lot of atheist people with
whom I speak and I talk about this in my
new book the right side of history a lot
of atheists use religious premises for
their own arguments so a lot of atheists
will assume that Free Will exists a lot
of atheists will assume that reason is
something worth worth doting upon but in
an atheistic materialist universe I
don't see why reason is anything special
reason is just a firing of neurons that
is evolutionarily beneficial presumably
so why should we value reason above for
example force if force is more
evolutionarily beneficial the the
attempt to build a morality on atheism
is the real problem I have there are
lots of atheists or wonderful people I
have lots of friends who are atheists
but building a morality on atheism I
think is nearly impossible Dominic says
hi Ben I need to get the bait Oh jokes
out of the way first
when I'm president we'll finally get the
man out of our Weed Man we have both
parties gather round a new monument of
our own design the Liberty bong okay now
my actual question out of all the
Democratic presidential candidates who
is the least of all evils right now
thank you for your time
Dominic well I've expressed a slight
preference for Pete but a buddy shesh
I'm still trying to figure out exactly
how he's pronounced Pete bought a gig
Pete but ashesh the South Bend Indiana
mayor mainly because he seems like he's
a little bit more considered than his
Democratic colleagues he'll throw out a
proposal then he'll say and maybe it
won't work
it's like okay I sort of appreciate that
I sort of and he's just as radical as a
lot of his friends but he seems like a
person who is slightly more open-minded
as far as as far as people who I think
would be the most damaging anybody who
polarizes along intersectional racial
lines is going to be deeply damaging to
the country and obviously open
socialists like Bernie Sanders well
be very damaging as well yeah there
there's a temptation to say Joe Biden
but I don't think the Joe Biden is
actually the quote-unquote moderate that
he purports to be whenever he's been in
a position of actual power he doesn't
govern like a moderate and he doesn't
speak like a moderate he just pretends
to be a moderate for purposes of
elections Emily says heibon you very
often cited the Brookings Institute
study what the three things one must do
in order to avoid being in poverty I
have a friend who's been something of a
sister to me since we were just toddlers
should some difficult circumstances up
in her late teens early twenties she's
at the point where she has violated all
three guidelines she had a daughter buy
a deadbeat dad she dropped out of high
school she's currently unemployed and
claims she's too depressed to work she
often attributes my success to being
lucky rather than decision-making but
she's near rock bottom and desperately
wants to turn her life around how do you
convince someone that luck has nothing
to do with success and more importantly
how does someone come back from Horrible
decision making she's family to me so I
hope you can help well the real question
is is she really ready to turn her life
around that really is the question
because the only person who's gonna be
able to turn her life around is her you
can advise her on anything if she
ignores the advice it's not gonna help
if she insists on being depressed and
blaming societal forces for her own
mistakes she's not going to fix her own
life if you take control and ownership
of your own life and you're ready to do
that and you're ready to take
responsibility and you're ready to take
action then you can make a practical
plan with her you can find out for
example what sort of financial support
does she need to make sure that her
daughter is taken care of while she goes
and finishes high school you can make
sure that there are people who are out
there willing to grant her a helping
hand there are lots of charitable people
out there lots of people give charity
for specifically this reason you can get
her in meshed in a social fabric find
friends and family of yours to help her
out there are lots of people who are
willing to help out but first she has to
commit herself to actually changing her
behavior and not blaming the situation
around her Sally says hi Ben like you
many people I grew up with Dana
deprotonated with a purpose in mind
however do you think a case can be made
that looking only at the opposite gender
for purposes of marriage could result in
the genders never engaging on a friendly
basis is dating only for marriage
somewhat responsible for a disconnect
between the genders so much so that in
traditional communities they seem to be
occupying two separate worlds thanks
Sally yeah I think this is a legitimate
criticism you know I grew up in an
Orthodox Jewish community there was a
separate boy school and a separate girls
school in our high school I think that's
a good thing because I think the risks
of a sexual interplay between boys and
girls in an unhealthy way in high school
is extremely high with that said once I
went to college did I hang out with
girls and I have friends who are girls
of course
anyway in law school some my best
friends were women that that's that's
great I mean I think that you should be
friends with members of the opposite sex
I also think that this is where siblings
really do play a role I have three
younger sisters so that means that I
knew kind of how girls act and and how
they think and and all of that is is
very helpful you do have to have a
well-rounded view of women in order to
know what to look for in a woman and a
lot of that has to do again with having
a healthy family life to having a father
and a mother who have a healthy marriage
you learn a lot about what you want in a
person of the opposite sex by looking at
your parents just as you learn a lot
about what you want to be by looking at
your parents of the same sex parents are
really important here really important
Connor says hey Ben I'm planning on
starting a blog featuring my political
commentary you have any tips on how to
gain an audience and a platform well you
know I think that the great temptation
and I know this because I went through
this at 17 the great temptation is to
write stuff that is deliberately
provocative to get attention
resist the temptation I wish that I had
I think most of the stupid stuff that I
feel like I've said in my career
happened very early in my career when I
was a tempting to do just that so I'd
recommend against that means the path
might be slightly longer but it would
also mean that you have less that you
regret saying back when you were a young
person publicly when it when it comes to
getting an audience and platform the
fact is that virtually every successful
company is based on marketing it means
that you have to find somebody who's
willing to invest a little bit of money
into marketing on Facebook you need to
make connections you need to reach out
to as many people as possible so that
they know that you exist you need to
reach out on Twitter you need to reach
out on Facebook you need to find people
who are willing to promote your stuff
that's the way to get started
JC says hey Ben I'm somebody who did not
finish college due to multiple reasons
I've always planned to go back for at
least an associate's degree in business
but I recently found out my brother's
college offers a degree in home making
if the cost is equal and my goal is
ultimately to be a stay-at-home mom but
the home making degree be a better
option or should I get the business
degree in case I need one in the future
what are your thoughts well I'm not sure
what the home making degree offers
because you can be a homemaker without a
degree so the question is what does the
degree do is it providing you a skill
set it's providing you a credential or
is it providing us
social fabric those are the three things
that education theoretically could use
skillset credential social fabric I'm
not sure what the homemaking degree does
for any of those things but again I
don't know the specific degree program
as far as business it does offer a
credential that is very useful it may
offer a skill set depending on the
program so I tend to lean toward the
idea that you should check out the
business program rather than the
homemaking program knowing nothing else
other than the titles of the program not
the contents of the program okay a
couple more here Jacobs has been when
you get your beta on can you please had
a few righteous in there your baito
impression always makes me think of this
eternal crush from Finding Nemo
Thanks I could use a good laugh
absolutely Jacob that is an excellent
idea because bado is indeed a righteous
radical dude Carson says hey Ben do you
think the Republican Party will take
overt steps to distance themselves from
Trump when campaigning in 2024 and
beyond do you think Trump winning or
losing a reelection will change this
thanks and love the show of course I
think every president finds themselves
distanced by the party in the future
there are candidates now who are
distancing themselves from half of
Barack Obama's institutional policies
how many Democrats you hear talking
about the wonders of Obamacare any
they're all talking about running away
from it
george w bush was thrown under the bus
as soon as humanly possible by future
members of the party in some ways that's
appropriate because you are not those
people and the easy intellectual
temptation is to lump people in with
former presidents of their own party
with that said is that intellectually
honest no I mean we're all individuals
we all have different ideas I wish
people could see that right I don't see
Kamala Harris in the same light in which
I see Barack Obama they don't have the
same policies I don't even see Joe Biden
in that same light I don't see Joe Biden
today in the same way that I saw Joe
Biden four years ago people are
constantly changing and shifting people
don't hold the same opinions that they
did even five minutes ago in many cases
okay time for some things that I like
and then some things that I hate so the
thing that I like today it's really kind
of a thing that I hate I didn't have any
things that I like I just sort of stuck
one of the things that I hate in the
things that I like this is pretty
spectacular though there is a nine year
old a nine year old who was featured by
the New York Times reading a book about
climate change to the adults I hate the
stuff more than I can tell you this
notion that nine year olds have
something deep to tell us about the
world nine year olds are innocent but
they are not wise nine year olds are
innocent but they are not knowledgeable
as
rule why am I supposed to take the
advice of a nine-year-old twice uma has
not read any of the IPCC reports upon
which he's basing his book about climate
change well he lectures me about how he
thinks we should balance the economic
needs of six billion people with the
need to lower carbon emissions so as to
lower the climate by a grand total of
three degrees Celsius over the next
century but nonetheless the neuro Times
featured this on their home page a video
of a nine year old boy reading a climate
change book to the adults so as to shame
us into into agreeing with the prospect
of the left the world is big and I am
small the Earth's in trouble here are
called under green warmers our demise
we're on track for more to rise goodbye
New York in Miami both cities swallowed
by the sea whose folks is all this
climate mess you grown-ups must confess
while seas burned and temperatures
soared you upped and left the Paris
Accord you think this is a fun rhyme
book
what's your inaction the earth will cook
my car enough of empty vows or plastic
bags or farting cows on a hot February
day you barbecued and went to play but
it's no time for celebration you totally
screwed my generation if we don't
protect all it's worth
prepare to say goodbye earth well a
little freakin Nostradamus over there my
goodness
and then you accept me that's that's
like from a that's from a terrible
Stanley Kubrick horror film my goodness
these little kids sitting in front of
the adults I mean that's shot like a
scene from a horror film even but then
with the up angles and everything the
little kid reading to you about how
you're gonna cook the earth one degree
warmer we all cook that is not true by
the way this is why I don't take my
advice from nine year olds yeah I got a
five-year-old I don't take my advice
from her either when you start saying
intelligent things then we'll start
taking your advice how about that and
New York Times what in the world I mean
I understand that the average op-ed
columnist at the New York Times may have
about the same level of rhetorical
capacity as this nine-year-old boy but
that doesn't mean you should be pushing
nine year olds and their and their
poetry about global warming on your home
page my goodness okay time for a thing
that I hate
so once again Tara rockets hit tel-aviv
yesterday they're aimed at Tel Aviv
they're shot down by the Iron Dome
there's some video of what that looked
like actually now you should understand
it terrifying that is those a rockets
flying over the largest most populous
city in Israel and then the iron dome
shoots down those those rockets that are
shot by Hamas from the Gaza Strip why
Israel why any state would be expected
to just sit there and take it as a as a
hostile terrorist power shot missiles at
their civilian centers is beyond me yet
if Israel retaliates undoubtedly they
will be condemned because that is the
way that our media works don't worry
guys those are not anti-semitic missiles
directed at random Jews in Israel those
are just anti-zionism missiles guys
don't worry about it we shouldn't worry
about any of the anti-semitism of chaos
really it's all just about they don't
like the settlement policy avi this why
they're shooting into Tel Aviv which
isn't a settlement okay time for one
more thing that I hate so once again
another day another college that has
that has banned me apparently so
Christian University has now banned me
this is Whitworth University a private
Christian University in Spokane
Washington they were being used as the
backup to Gonzaga which is also in
Spokane Washington Gonzaga had banned me
and then when they finally offered us a
venue they offered us a 20,000 seat
venue which like that that is not useful
to us thank you so much Gonzaga finally
the the student body held a vote the
students at Whitworth University held a
vote on whether they should allow me to
show up and the vote was tied 9 to 9 and
that's when the president of a WSU broke
the tie and voted against me speaking on
campus there was a 90 minute
back and forth and then there was a vote
to stop ya from inviting me in the first
place the director of Student Activities
Jason Chapman said these issues are not
simple there was not a clear majority I
think this is a reflective of today's
political climate at the end of the day
I think that this Student Union stuck to
the platform they ran on last year of
transparency and unity yeah cuz
transparency and unity is don't allow
any of the opinions you don't like on
campus well done over there okay final
thing that I hate today so Samantha be
who is the least funny human in the
world like legitimately in the world you
cannot find any less funny human than
Samantha me
she's very angry at Democrats for not
standing up for Aloha nomar's
anti-semitism which she just
characterizes as anti-israel Samantha
bee is the hack of hacks but for some
reason she has a job I think we all know
what the reason is it's that she's on
the Left Democrats want to be the big
tent diverse party they're more than
willing to pose with Omar on magazine
covers but when she tried to talk about
a truly difficult topic which is her job
as an elected official and her life was
in danger they kind of threw her under
the bus Ilhan Omar went from being a
Somalian refugee to a fearless
congresswoman on the hill and has
demonstrated that she is willing to
learn okay no she has not demonstrated
any willingness to learn and there was
no debate on the hill she said something
anti-semitic and you want her defended
because she's a member of the
intersectional coalition end of story
okay we'll be back here a little bit
later today with two more hours you
should subscribe you should also go pick
up a copy of my book which comes out
next week if you want that book to
arrive on your doorstep the day that it
comes out then now is the time to go
order it you can get a signed copy at
premiere collectibles calm slash at Ben
Shapiro we'll see you in a little while
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19